the titles all the languages together so
let me start off by pointing out that
there are a lot of programming languages
out there you know here are a bunch of
logos from most the general-purpose ones
but there are numerous dsls you might
write a whole bunch yourself at work so
what I want to talk about today is is
how do we go about making it easier to
use a mix of languages when developing
software alright so there are many good
reasons for wanting to use different
languages at the same time in the same
software system we this is almost sort
of cliche by now that different
languages are suited for different tasks
so for instance if you're writing an
application in Oakland Hamill perhaps
you have some memory intensive our
performance intensive component that you
want to go and implement and rust maybe
as part of the same application you need
to implement some sort of a protocol so
you can use something like a DSL called
Rago which lets you easily write down
finite state machines other reasons you
could have an existing code base maybe
you've been stuck with it for a while
and along comes a nice new nifty
programming language and you'd like to
start using that but you can't throw
away your existing code base so that's
another reason for wanting to be able to
use multiple languages together at the
same time in an application now that
said developing multi language software
is hard the world just doesn't sort of
set up to do this too easily so normally
we just sort of make do every language
has a CF Fi or Java has a J&I so you you
I mean it's you can always have your
language talk to see if you need to talk
to another language you might need to
get to it go through the CF Fi to talk
to that other language because you don't
know how to talk to each other directly
the other sort of popular approach is
micro services so here you basically
take your application and you split it
up into sort of pieces and then you
figure out how you want to talk across
these different services these should
this is you know it works very well but
the issue with this is that we're sort
of stuck with a coarse-grained rather
than a fine
approach there's really nothing out
there that lets us mix languages
together in a more fine-grained fashion
if we wanted to sometimes now there are
other issues with developing
multi-language software you know there's
been a lot of people have spent time and
effort on tools that help you reduce
boilerplate and there are many issues to
do with tooling and IDE support so for
instance if you have an identifier in
one language and you need to then refer
to it from another you know it would be
nice if the IDE is provided support for
those kind of cross language links this
talk is not about tooling support I will
say something about tooling support at
the end towards the end but let me get
to what this talk is about and what kind
of multi language software mixing I want
so I'm gonna start with an example
suppose that you have a no camel
application and you want to write part
of you know you you need to use rust to
write some high-performance component so
I'm not gonna show you a whole
application or you know tons of code but
I'm going to show you something small
and idealized let me actually start so
it's the Oh camel is calling the rest
but let me start with the rest side so
here we have two functions that there's
an Alec buffer so rust in rust we're
going to allocate a vector and pass it
over to O camel and then when a camel is
done with that vector we are going to
get o camel is going to call this return
buffer function and you know essentially
pass it back to rust now what our buffer
is doing is it's it's basically
allocating this vector with capacity to
so for those of you who don't know how
vectors work in rust and a vector in
rust is basically a struct with three
fields it has a pointer capacity and a
length the capacity is how much memory
you have total and the length is how
many fields you've filled up so far how
many slots you've filled up so far so we
push a number into it and we pass it
over to a camel and then when we come
back a return buffer will just sort of
get take the vector and go and update
slot one in that picture okay so it's
yeah
here's the old camel code so first let
me just sort of step through the
categories of this first we just have to
do some boilerplate work because we need
a type vex so that we can get the point
or capacity and length but here is our
declaration for the foreign functions
the aleck buffer and return buffer that
are sitting in rust and then what do we
actually do well we call a lip buffer
here and we get a vector and it's V and
then we do the bookkeeping to get the
point or the capacity and the length and
the actual pointer to the buffer then we
do sensible things we basically go ahead
and we store at we store at slot one of
that vector and we update the length so
we're being good citizens we're updating
the length too - all right because we've
just pushed another thing onto that
picture and then we return the buffer
back - to rust now notice the very last
line after I returned the buffer tube to
rust Oh camel is still using it you can
continue to go and up and go and update
that memory but that of course is a
problem because the hope you know not a
big deal about rust is the ownership
discipline which makes sure that Edmund
for any piece of memory there's only one
owner at a time and here even though
we've called return buffer and passed
the vector back to rust we're continuing
to use it so basically the problem here
is that Oh camel doesn't understand
rusks ownership discipline right it
doesn't know that this memory needs to
be handled carefully and you know you
can't you can't just stash away a
pointer in the Oh camel code when you're
telling rusts that here you go you can
have your memory back ok so here's
another slightly different example but
just to make a different point so this
is simpler I just have a structure s
here in rust
and I have two functions F 1 and F 2
that I'm not even going to show there on
the old camel side so basically what we
do this this example is about
refactoring so here I have a version of
this code that basically allocates you
know I have the structure I initialize
the fields at 10 and then I call F 1 and
I pass it X and then I clone X into y
and then go ahead and call F 2 and then
return the clone structure
now if Oakham o is behaving well and not
stashing away pointers to rust memory
then it would be perfectly okay to get
rid of this clone we could just go ahead
and you know straight away basically the
only thing that could happen is f2 could
mutate X somehow but if camel didn't
stash away a pointer then f2 shouldn't
update my structure so I should just be
able to return X without cloning it ok
so but the problem is that if oak Amal
does stash a pointer it can f2 can then
go ahead and update X all right so it's
just another way in which a camel
doesn't understand rusts ownership
discipline but now it affects
refactoring so let's talk about the
bigger picture now I'm gonna zoom out a
little bit when you have Oh camel and
rust how does a programmer go about
figuring out if ownership is violated
well they really don't have much
recourse other than to compile the code
link it together and run it and then see
what errors crop up and then debug right
because this nice ownership discipline
has been violated now you have to kind
of go and sort of figure out what what
the issue was and the question I want to
ask really sort of the bigger question
throughout this talk is can we not force
programmers to have to do that can we
instead bring this reasoning about you
know whether I can safely put together
components and whether the other
language will violate my guarantees or
invariants can we bring this sort of
reasoning back
source-level okay I'm not gonna answer
that question straight away I'm gonna
show you another problem so so far I was
talking about two general-purpose
languages but I don't want to leave out
the DSL the same sort of situation
applies here I'm gonna talk about DSL in
a very idealized way I'm not gonna show
you anything specific but just to sort
of give you a flavor for how the problem
exists there - so imagine that we are
implementing a web server and we're
we're doing it using some some nice view
so also perhaps we use a stateful DSL to
implement listener terminating control
CFG DSL for the protocol parser and
maybe we're using some other third DSL
to implement the spam system or
something now what I want to focus on
here is that protocol parser it's
written in a terminating DSL it would be
a nice thing if protocol parsing
actually terminated so this is a very
careful choice okay now what we want to
know is how these how my student
listening the stateful DSL on my
protocol parser in the terminating DSL
interact in particular the concern here
is does the non termination from the
stateful language leak into my
terminating language right because then
the main guarantee the main reason I'm
using my DSL would be gone okay
and again the picture is pretty much the
same even if these are DSL even if
they're embedded dsls you normally have
to understand what's going on after
compilation or macro expansion either
macro expansion into your host language
or after compilation - some common
target and then you have to run it and
see what happens and see what goes wrong
and the question is the same again how
can we allow this sort of reasoning to
be brought up to the source level okay
so before I start giving you a proposal
for how I think we should
let's just sort of take a look at one
one way so one way that we could reason
at the source level is we could start
designing multi
languages that give you a semantics of
interoperability between the two
languages that we want to put together
so you could define multi-language for
interoperability between Oh camel and
Russ that would take care of I mean it
would be a lot of work but it would take
care of my first example and people are
working on this kind of thing another
and then for my second example we could
define a semantics or interoperability
between the terminating dsl on the
stateful DSL
but maybe you see where i'm going with
this there are if there are n different
languages in the world and we need to
define pairwise and Tropper ability
between all of them this is an N squared
problem
so the idea does not scale so this is a
really large part of what I want to
advocate today because I do not want to
propose an N squared solution ok all
right so let's step back I'm going to
say a few words before I before I start
talking about solutions I want to say a
few words about the current state of
programming language design and
implementation I guess so what do we
currently do we have some nice languages
out there languages we like I've
actually quite especially picked
typesafe languages and put them up there
so we have ml rust or languages that we
at least believe are type safe we have
ml rust and Java how do we researchers
go off and prove lots of the things to
try to get there but so how do we design
these languages well the way that work
happens you know at least from an
academic standpoint we can talk about
like ml with with rust people are trying
to prove the soundness with Java after
Java came out there are a whole bunch of
researchers who went out there and tried
to prove that it is in fact type sound
so we design these languages they have a
nice type system and they guarantee type
safety so they give us a whole bunch of
guarantees they're good languages they
give us guarantees we can rely on those
guarantees when we write our code and we
reason about our code tools that we use
for refactoring can rely on those
guarantees to to do the refactoring and
have some sense of oh yeah this this
refactoring should
gentlemen because these are the
properties of the language so we do that
but then we go and implement these
languages now what I want to say is that
these language specifications are
incomplete because they don't account
for linking our design is done in a sort
of silo mindset so then when we go and
implement these languages we open up
these gigantic escape hatches so with
you know language like ml would have the
CIF of five for rust there's unsafe code
for Java there's the gni so we know that
interoperability is something we need we
cannot have a language that is a silo we
need to interoperate with something at
least with C code so we open up the
escape hatches all the guarantees that
we so painstakingly proved at least the
researchers proved they're gone at this
point we tell the programmers to be
careful right it's not a good state of
affairs and the essence of my talk today
is how do we change that state of
affairs so I want to advocate that we
start to somehow rethink PL design
instead of opening up a gigantic escape
hatch with these FF eyes that bring in
all sort of insecurities and
vulnerabilities how about we go about it
in a more systematic fashion
open up small principled escape hatches
or principle design principles FF eyes
so let's not do this yeah C F fi and
stuff let's talk about what a principled
ff5 might feel like what would it be
um so if I want ml and Russ to talk to
each other ie ml designer would like to
go teach ml something about rusts
ownership discipline but I don't want to
teach it rusts ownership and borrowing
discipline cuz that's way too
complicated can I extract out the
essence of rusts ownership discipline
and design and extension an FF I for ml
that is safe but that introduces just
the concept of linear types linear types
basically give you this the
a disability to reason about the fact
that you have a resource and only one
part of your program let's say will have
access or a capability for this resource
at any point in time if we have that we
should be able to get very very far with
with respect to safe and Tropper ability
with rust we don't need to know about
the intricacies of borrowing in on the
ml side rust can handle that okay so
that's a thesis these principles
emphathize
I call them linking types so what we
want is to design linking types
extensions that support safe
interoperability with other languages
all right so suppose that I sort of
carry this this idea further now let's
say I wanted my ML code to interact with
a pure terminating DSL all right so all
programs written in that DSL will
terminate well ml doesn't really have a
notion of purity so if ml interacts with
this DSL it could easily pass a
nonterminating function to the DSL and
then you know you have a program that
doesn't terminate okay so could I teach
ml about one additional concept let's
call it purity or termination I'll call
it pure so you see I'm sort of opening
up what I'm calling I'm essentially
advocating that we take ml and we
provide the ml programmers with with
these simple features these additional
types that don't exist in the language
already okay and we let them use that to
annotate how they wish to interoperate
with different categories of languages
out there and different categories takes
me to my next point what I'm advocating
here is that we only need these linking
types extensions to interact with
behaviors or features that are not
expressible in your language so think of
these linking types as shadow sort of
type system a richer type system that's
sitting in the back you know of your
language only you can now leverage these
specifications to get better
interoperability actually let me
and and so you should never need if if
russ has linearity and some other
language has some concept which looks
like linear types or ownership then we
should only need to add linear types to
ml once and then be able to interact
with that whole category of languages
now this is an untested hypothesis but
that's the that's the conjecture or
that's what I'm advocating okay so so
Lincoln types are about raising program
or reasoning back up to the source level
it's about giving the ml programmer a
way to say I am going to get a vector
from rust and I'm going to treat it in a
certain fashion so that I don't end up
violating rusts ownership discipline
okay so let me jump back to the example
that I had I'm gonna go through the O
camel and rust example and then I'm
going to go through the the dsls example
okay so here's the Oh camel and rust
remember rust had a lock buffer and
return buffer those two functions that
allocate a vector and then the other one
that receives the vector back from oh
camel so here's our code here was the
problem on this last line after we've
returned the vector to rust we still
keep using it on the O camel side and
therefore we violate trusts ownership
discipline so the solution which have
sort of hinted at already is let's
design a linking type extension for oh
camel that teaches or camel about linear
types that adds linear types to the type
language in a sense for oh camel so
let's see how if we do that how would we
be able to solve this problem so say
here are sort of made up notation but
you know essentially what I what I want
is I want to be able to annotate on the
Oh camel side I want to be able to say
that when I call a lock buffer it gives
me back a linear vector it's linear it
can't be you know it has to be treated
linearly only one part of the code can
sort of manipulate it or own it at a
time
and then return buffer will be given
that linear vector back when we call
returned offer now when we call a low
puffer we get back knee now because of
the type up there for our buffer this
has to be a linear vector if it's a
linear vector and I'm going to sort of
assume that we it's a linear vector with
these three structures inside but we're
gonna treat the things inside the linear
thing linearly as well okay so the
pointer the capacity and the length
essentially what ends up happening by
the time we get down here and we return
the vector using return buffer what
should happen is that the linear vector
V along with all of those linear things
underneath it so to speak the point or
the capability the length and the actual
buffer the memory should all the
ownership for that should all get passed
back to rust because it was linear I
can't keep it and give it away so I have
I just gave it away that means that this
line should no longer type check because
now I'm trying to use the buffer there
to store at index one and that's not
allowed so now when I say that it won't
type check what I'm imagining is that
when I designed that linking type
extension and I taught Oh camel about
linear linear types I also design an
extended type checker that understands
how to deal with linear types and that
extend the type checker at the mention
of linearity will basically catch this
as a type error okay technically
speaking I just want to sort of flash
this slide and and show you what what's
going on I'm not extending a camel in
any way except for extending its type
language so you can think I'm using
colors to sort of keep these things
apart
Oh camels types are in orange and these
linking types there's this language of
linking types which is richer and you
can see that basically all I'm doing is
I'm adding this Lin annotation which I
you know this optional linearity
annotation that I can attach on to a
type okay so you can use it where you
wish to but you don't need to it's
optional and this is the optional part
this is to be this should be done in a
way
so that you know programmers never have
to use any linking type extended
annotations unless they really want to
interact with the feature where they
wish to say something about you know
using resources linearly so there has to
be a default translations from the types
of the core language so camel into the
linking type extended language and I
won't say more about that but I'll come
come back to it with another example
later so going back to the web server so
here had this instance of a terminating
DSL and a stateful DSL and we want to
know how we can reason about the
interaction about you know we want to
make sure that non termination doesn't
leak from the stateful DSL to the
terminating DSL now here I'm actually
gonna before I jump in and start going
through some details sometimes you might
want to you know just accept non
terminating functions it really ought to
be the programmers choice sometimes
escape hatches are good as long as they
are done in a deliberate way right so
when when it's the csfi we really don't
have a choice we're not being very
deliberate about any of it here I'm
gonna try to show walk you through an
example where we're gonna try to think
about how to deliberately violate let's
say the the termination discipline of
the DSL but let's see okay so I'm gonna
do this with a couple of really
idealized languages so I have pure line
which is my term which is my stand-in
for my terminating DSL and it just has
you know unit integer and function types
and I have a state line which is my
state representative from write stateful
DSL and that just has ml so mutable
references in addition to whatever we
have in the orange language in the pure
language okay and now the question is
how do we reason in the pure language
when linking with the stateful language
okay now what does this word reason mean
so in particular I want to talk about
reasoning about refactoring
so up there I have a function that takes
another function a unit to end function
as an input it's called C and it calls C
twice okay so since we're in a pure
language this since we're in a pure
language there are no effects there's no
memory I can update there I can't go
into an infinite loop so it should be
perfectly okay to take the the program
where I call C twice and rewrite it into
the program where I call C only once
those two should be perfectly equivalent
right so that kind of refactoring should
be justified if we stay in this pure
language alone all right
so but what happens when we go and link
with some code that's been written in
the stateful language right we want to
mix code from the two languages so let's
take a look at this example so here I
have a counter and it takes this
function f prime which I'm going for
which I'm going to pass in some orange
code some code from the from the pure
language ok so what's happening is that
my counter the blue code so I have a
stateful counter implemented in state in
the state full language what I'm doing
is I'm allocating a new reference and
then I'm basically every single time
this function is called I am going to
I'm going to return a counter which
every single time it's called it goes
ahead and updates that counter and then
returns the number that's stored in the
counter and and basically what happens
is that if I go ahead and and stick in
the or the pure language code which
calls C twice into the you know linked
with that then I end up incrementing the
counter twice you see because what's
happened is that the orange function
accepts a counter is input that counter
is stateful now so calling it twice
means I get a two back but if I take the
refactored code I I'm only calling the
counter once so I get a 1 back
so clearly the refactoring that was
justified in the orange language alone
and the pure language alone is no longer
justified when I'm mixing things up with
the stateful language okay so yeah when
linking with that language refactoring
is no longer correct so so the question
of is this particular is a particular
refactoring correct it kind of depends
on a bunch of things and it depends on
what exactly it's linked with so if we
were linking that code up there if the
only C that we to accept it as input was
in fact a unit to end function from my
pure language then this refactoring is
perfectly okay right but if I'm linking
with a unit to end function that's from
my stateful language well it still looks
like a unit to end function but it's
blue it's not orange it's from the
stateful language being a unit to end
function in the stateful language means
that it is stateful it's not pure it
might diverge it might allocate a
reference etc right so if we link with a
blue unit to end function the stateful a
stateful 1 then this refactoring is no
longer okay because there's a potential
for for you know two different calls our
effect 'fl so you can't just get rid of
one of them so what I'm proposing is
that the programmer should be able to
specify which one they want when they're
building multi-language software because
sometimes you might want
I ought to link with pure code that's
when you really you know you're worrying
about the termination properties of your
code but sometimes you might want an
escape hatch so you might want to say oh
I'm perfectly happy linking with
stateful unit to end functions okay so
it shouldn't be that you have a nice
language which gives you lots of
guarantees and usually you never should
be able you know you should never be
able to step out of it okay so the way
I'm gonna do this is with a I'm gonna
sort of allow the programmer to specify
which one they want is by developing a
linking type extension for my pure
language so again the pure language is
orange and Ling
type extension is this pink and
basically what I'm doing this time is in
my linking types extended language I
have all the original types unit int and
functions but for functions I'm being
careful about whether or not this
function is pure so the function has
this type T to R 0 T the 0 just means
there are 0 effects okay so that's the
type of a pure function and at the
bottom you see the type of a stateful
function this is a function that takes
the t is input and then returns some if
it terminates it returns some value of
that result type t but it can
potentially have effects so it could go
into an infinite loop or it could update
some memory etc ok so that's my linking
type extension and here's what it buys
me now if the programmer has pure Lang
extended with the linking type extension
in pink the programmer suddenly has a
vocabulary for saying which one they
want do they want the orange unit to end
function if so they can write it as I
want pure functions that return in int
if they want the blue unit to end
function then they can write I want the
impure or the stateful functions that
take a unit and return some value or
that should have been int over there but
can potentially have an effect okay so
let's talk about refactoring for pure
inputs then going back to our example if
the programmer specified that the the
code the function needs to take a
counter that is a pure function then
that refactoring is perfectly correct
and what happens is if the function is
only allowed to take pure functions as
input then we are trying to pass in that
blue code which is stateful so it does
just won't type check its ill types of c
required since F requires pure code now
if on the other hand the programmer had
said yeah I'm in a pure language but I'm
perfectly happy to take stateful
functions as input effectual functions
as input then they would annotate their
input with
unit to effect full function that
returns an integer now in this case this
refactoring is not okay right and what's
happened is that the programmer by
writing down that annotation is suddenly
aware of the fact that this refactoring
is okay and will not do it because they
can see the type so it gives you a local
way of thinking about what refactoring
you're allowing and what you're not
right so it's it's giving programmers
control and information so in this case
back to our example if we have the
function C annotated with I'm you know
I'm happy to accept stateful functions
then this code is perfectly well typed
because well F accepts stateful code so
so we're okay all right now I want to
come back to this minimal annotation
burden thing which I mentioned earlier
as well but I'll say a little bit more
about it now so what we have here is I
have a function in my orange language
and my annotation says that I'm happy to
accept unit to end functions that are
pure now that it would be a real pain if
programmers had to write that down right
for that they should just be able to
write the orange unit to end okay
so when we design these linking types
extensions one of the principles is that
there should be default in translation
we should be able to provide a default
translation that looks something like
this
when you do the design the linking type
extension in this case I'm calling it
pure line plus process you provide a
default translation that turns orange
types into their corresponding pink
types the core language types into the
linking types extended language types
and here you can see that the only
interesting thing that's happening is
that we are noting that any orange t1 to
t2 function the pure language functions
is going to be documented as in our
linking types extended language as a
function that takes a t1 returns a t2
but is pure right the zero indicates
that it won't have any effects
I'm gonna skip that part okay so so far
I've talked about linking types
extensions so this gives programmers a
way to go and sprinkle in additional
annotations if they wish to okay so I
said I want to bring sort I want to
bring back bring reasoning back to the
source level so this takes me a little
bit of the way but it doesn't take me
all the way and here's the next big
thing that I want to talk about how do
we catch cross language type errors and
maybe a question is have we caught them
already based on what I've said so far
the answer is no so let's just go back
to our example so we had this example
where you know now that I've sprinkled
in linearity annotations all over the
place
my oh camel code cannot make use of this
buffer at the end after returning the
vector to to rust but what if my ml
programmer doesn't feel like sprinkling
in the linear type annotations how does
my on the rust side how does rust nor
the rust programmer might be a different
person
how do they know that their guarantees
have not been violated so what I want to
emphasize is we're still really in the
same place as before yeah because if the
ml programmer doesn't use my nice
linking types extensions I still have no
way of telling the rust programmer that
something bad is going to happen at
least not until they've compiled and
linked etc right and and then try to
wade through the errors okay so we need
a couple more things we need one more
big piece of the puzzle so oh I just
said this just because oh camel
programmer can annotate does not mean
she will okay so how do we catch these
errors across languages when the
expectations of the more richly typed
language in this case you know rust with
its ownership discipline when those
expectations are not met how do we
warned that programmer so the answer is
type preserving compilation so tie
preserving when you when you build a
type preserving compiler you take
programs and your type programs in your
high low
language and you translate them you
don't just type check the program and
throw away the types you instead take
all the types and translate them with
the code to lower and lower levels of
the compiler Java for instance java to
java bytecode is a type preserving
translation that that part is a tie
preserving compiler same thing for C
sharp to the CIL etc but the the issue
there is that you know those are rather
sort of front-end passes bytecode Java
bytecode is still very high-level
there's still a lot more compilation to
be done but this idea has been carried
down all the way to assembly in fact
this work dates back to the mid 90s so
what I'd like to propose is that we use
type preserving compilers because these
and I'll tell you how it solves the
problem about catching cross language
errors in a second but these type
essentially this idea of having type
annotations in the target code is really
powerful because it gives you
specifications at the low level which
tell you something about the invariants
and it can be in high level invariants
translated into the appropriate
low-level invariants and you can use
those type annotations to then check
certain things at linked um and perhaps
disallow linking if you need to if your
invariants aren't met right your
requirement specifications aren't met
okay so let's go back to Oak Amal and
rust so I'm just gonna show the the
basic idea with a simple example so here
I have my alloc buffer in rust and
remember now I'm saying oh our buffer
and in rust actually that Lyn annotation
should not have been there sorry that's
a mistake it's just on the rough side
our buffer just has the type void - Beck
right but vectors are owned in rust okay
on this side let's say my old camel
programmer did not sprinkle in a line'
annotation on Beck okay so the Oh camel
programmer still claims that a log
buffer it takes a void and returns a
vector but it's not linear so how does
type reserving
compilation help me catch errors well
when I translate the type for my Alok
buffer on the rust side what I should
get down here and mind you even though
that should just say void Tyvek after
type preserving compilation the type
that I should get for my Alok buffer
function would be void tool in vector
what I'm assuming here is that my typed
target language understands linearity
and when someone compiles rust if if
someone is doing a proper type
preserving compiler for rust they would
take all of the stuff about owner or
ownership and borrowing and translate
them into an appropriate linearity type
discipline in the target so it's a tough
thing to do but it buys you a lot okay
so if we have if we use a tie preserving
compiler that's the annotation we would
get for our buffer now if the O'Connell
programmer did not say that
a load buffer is void to linear back
even though we have linking types on
that side then the type preserving
compiler will produce this type on the
Oh camel side it will just be void to
vector and because void to vector does
not match void tool in vector this means
that we can't allow the game to proceed
some violation is being you know some
something is happening bad is happening
something is violating rusts
expectations okay so so at least so it
gives us a sort of long path right we're
going from the top we're doing type
preserving compilation but then we're
creating a medium where we have the
right information that we can use to
match things up and figure out if the
expectations on the rest side are met or
not okay all right
these types don't match so if you want
to say something a little bit more
generally stepping away from just Oh
camel and rust about how type preserving
compilation helps us find these cross
language type errors I'm not going to do
it with explicit types and showing you
how to translate them but I'm gonna do
it with shapes so it should essentially
the idea is
one language language one over here and
you have language two over there let's
say in language one I write a function
that accepts a star and returns a
triangle all right now on the language
two side I know how to write a kind of a
star okay and that's why what I want to
do is I want to take this function and
link it up with that star which acts as
the input to my function okay
now the idea of tie preserving
compilation here is that when I compile
language one in compiled language - if
how however I translate my star on this
side my blue language star my language
to star if I end up getting a star of
this particular shape in the target
language okay and if that star matches
up the star that this guy expects then
I'm good then I can allow this linking
to proceed okay because the types match
alright
if on the other hand the types don't
match so for instance Lang - the star is
still translating as before but perhaps
there's something about this particular
language where the translation for the
purple star is is not that red star it's
in fact some sort of a red circle and it
doesn't match up so the expectations of
this function are that it wants at least
when translated down to the target level
code what it wants has this circle shape
circle type refuel and it doesn't match
up with what it's getting on the other
side okay so that in a nutshell is the
intuition for how type reserving
compilation can help us catch these
errors okay so these types don't match
and we should report an error
now the story doesn't end there once you
once we build these type preserving
compilers right now I've just shown you
a sketch of an idea that you know if we
have this information down at the target
level then we should be able to match
things up and if we can match things up
then we can report errors so it's sort
of like informations coming down from
tops it's going like this and we can
report an error over to this side right
okay um so in the long term this
information at least having this
information should be extremely valuable
we'll still need to do a lot of work in
terms of ID ease that take this
information and nicely display it to
users right because if you really want
to build multi-language software you
want the programmer sitting at the top
and not having to worry about any of
this low-level information right so we
need tools they need IDE is that that
take this information and appropriately
communicate the problems to programmers
okay but hopefully the shape idea gives
you a sense of how we might be able to
do that okay so let's move on the next
point I want to make is that we don't
just want type preserving compilation we
in fact want refactoring preserving
compilation so in other words if you the
programmer are relying it's if you
expect certain rewriting certain
refactorings to be correct in your
source language given the properties of
the source language they might be type
safety guarantees or whatever else and
you have not used one of these linking
types principles escape hatches to say
that I'm okay with this refactoring not
holding all right because you can do
that we saw that the example with the
blue and orange languages read the pure
and stateful languages if I choose to I
can say oh I'm happy to accept a
stateful function which means that I'm
happy to give up on a particularly
refactoring pattern okay so if I choose
to give up on certain refactoring then
regardless whatever I chose I the
programmer programmers god compiler
writer should not be making decisions so
whatever refactoring the the programmer
wants they can indicate with with these
annotations and then we want to take the
programmers wishes and make sure that
the refactorings that they expect to
hold in the source program still hold
after the code is compiled down to the
target okay so why is this tough well
basically what happens is that at the
target level you have assembly or
something sufficiently low level that
you know your low-level language can do
lots of things that you can't possibly
do in a high level
you could have various jumps and disrupt
control flow and try to you know
basically violate correctness of
refactorings that way so in order to
preserve the correctness of refactoring
you have conceptually speaking what the
compiler must do is prevent linking with
all code that could possibly tell the
difference between you know version 1 of
some code and its refactored counterpart
okay now the key idea and this is you
know is that we can actually use type
preserving compilers and type preserving
translations in a way that we can use
them as a sort of lever to turn the knob
and say ah the type something of type T
translates to something of this
complicated type but it's linking with
something that I'd really don't want to
be linking with hmm is there a way to
take this complicated type and make it a
bit more tight so that I prevent that
linking and all that happens when you
design your compilers type translation
okay so basically what I'm saying is
that the compiler should be following
the directives of the source level types
in some sense but I'm giving you an
escape hatch linking types are the
escape hatch if the programmer says that
they never want to link with code that
they can't you know that violates
refactoring is great but if the
programmer says that they're happy with
the linking with certain things that
violate refactorings then the compiler
should do that okay all right so this
idea of refactoring preserving
compilations also known as equivalence
preserving compilation or secure
compilations in the literature and
there's been quite a bit of work on it
recently okay
so I've talked about a lot of high level
ideas sort of laid out you know the
abstract said this talk is about how do
we change the status quo when it comes
to building multi-language suffers this
is this is a talk about a lot of pieces
that that don't exist yet they exist in
certain partial forms we know how to do
type preserving compilers we have had a
lot of research in the last decade on
how to do these refactoring preserving
or secure compilers but we're not all
the way for instance to assembly yet so
what I want to do
next is give you and even with linking
types extensions we have a lot of
experience in the last couple of decades
designing very rich type systems that
can keep these different sorts of
effects you know separate from each
other
purity state control etc so this sort of
agenda is really about how do we take
all of those pieces and put them
together to make multi-language software
easier to build so let me tell you about
ongoing work so basically in my group
this is the next most direct thing that
we're sort of working on so this is the
mulberry project mall for multi-language
so what we are currently trying to do is
take ml and figure out what exactly the
linking types extensions should look
like that give us the right kind of
interoperability with rust in the way
that I've tried to sketch out today we
are also taking a pure language and
designing a separate linking type
extension to interact with pure with
features from that pure language and to
put all of this together what's gonna
make it work is if we can build type
preserving and refactoring preserving
compilers all the way down to our very
richly typed target language so we are
building this on top of web assembly and
now there are a lot of criteria that go
into this this you know richly typed was
them that we are trying to design
basically if you're trying to take
languages at the high level languages
that are so different from each other
one is pure one a stateful one has
linearity and you know you might have
more like I'll show you more then what
you really need at the target level is a
language with the type system that's so
rich that can keep all of these
different effects so to speak apart so
for instance that language that target
language should be able to say this is
that components memory you better not
touch it okay there have to be
specifications that we can write for
making sure that that's the case or for
just encapsulating state
and keeping that away from pure code so
that you know effects don't leak in the
pure code in a longer-term sense we'd
actually like to attempt to compile
galena down to the same rigidly type
target language and my student William
Bowman's actually been doing some work
on type preserving compilation oh sorry
I forgot Mina the coq theorem prover
which is used for verification in the
community how do we compile that so that
we can actually have high assurance
verified code mixed together with let's
say low assurance ml code etc without
violating all of the high assurance
guarantees that you painstakingly prove
when you do verification now I'm sure
you've noticed that I haven't said
anything about on type languages
throughout this talk that's sort of
intentional because in my group at least
we're trying to tackle how do we mix
different typed languages with very
different features we're trying to take
that as a first step but there are ideas
out there which you know sort of that we
could use in order to make statically
typed and dynamically typed languages
mixed together so for instance if we are
compiling scheme and C or something down
the road to the same typed target
language conceptually at least what we
would need is we would need this richly
typed wasum that we want to design to to
be able to interact with less richly
typed was a more untyped or dynamically
typed wasn't bazan is already a type
safe language but with a very minimal
gary type safety guarantee whereas what
I'm imagining on the richly typed side
is much stronger guarantees so this
really is an instance of gradual typing
and one of my students max knew is
actually working on on foundations of
gradual typing that we're hopeful will
sort of down the road lead to some clues
for that okay so the other thing is for
ML we're interested in looking at
interactions with a language like scheme
so our ml right now
case we don't sort of have first-class
control in the language so this gives us
an opportunity to experiment with
designing a linking type extension that
lets us deal with that so let me just
sort of give you some takeaways yeah
so what I've talked about today is that
multi-language software should be easier
to build but easier said than done so
hopefully you know you've found this
idea of linking types useful basically I
think that it gives us a way to rethink
all of language design and start
thinking carefully about what principle
data files we could add to our existing
languages so that we don't just open up
a gigantic escape hatch and let all
sorts of bugs in but in order to make
all of this vision a reality in order to
make all of the pieces fit together what
we need is principal software tool
chains from multi language software and
for that things like type preserving and
refactoring preserving compilation Artie
and because they also give you this
power to report cross language type
errors and allow programmers if to
reason at the source level okay I will
leave you with one last slide so this is
this has a link to my group and I put
pictures of all my students up there and
in particular let me call out Daniel
Patterson his dissertation is the one on
this topic that know that the bulk of
this talk was about so all five of them
are here so if you can't find me please
find them they will be happy to tell you
in more detail what we what we are up to
and you can find publications and other
information on that website thanks so
much
[Applause]